Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速告知大家一个正在发生的好消息。如果你曾想过如何创造能够为你工作的收入，而不是不断用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）主讲的“冲刺经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Have you ever considered what additional challenges during breastfeeding and the perinatal
这些原则都对你适用。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接参加挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士一对一辅导一小时的机会。你想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个快速私信，我会把所有细节发给你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。你是否曾考虑过，在母乳喂养和围产期，
period might crop up for South Asian women? In this episode, Zainab Khan and I discuss the social, cultural and healthcare barriers these women face and discuss how we can provide better support for them and their families. Hope you find this so useful. Hi, welcome along. I am Dr. Marianne and it is lovely to have you here. If you haven't already caught the previous episode I did with Zainab, where we were looking more broadly at some of the additional mental and physical health factors that might be around for people with South Asian heritage, please do check that episode out as well,
南亚女性可能会遇到哪些额外的挑战？在本期节目中，扎伊纳布·汗（Zainab Khan）和我讨论了这些女性所面临的社会、文化和医疗保健障碍，并探讨了我们如何为她们及其家人提供更好的支持。希望你会觉得这非常有用。嗨，欢迎收看。我是玛丽安博士，很高兴你能来到这里。如果你还没有看过我之前与扎伊纳布合作的那期节目——我们在其中更广泛地探讨了南亚血统人群可能面临的一些额外心理和身体健康因素，请务必也去看看那期节目，
or I will link it for you at the end of this episode too. I hope you will find this episode to be really illuminating. And if you do enjoy it, please do rate and review if listening on Apple Podcasts. If you are on Spotify, you can rate it. Please do drop me a comment, drop me a like, share it with your friends. Subscribe to the channel. It is the kindest thing you can do for any podcaster and it's entirely free. What is not to like there? Let's dive in and I'll look forward to catching up with you on the other side.
或者我会在本期节目的末尾为你提供链接。我希望你会觉得这期节目真的很有启发性。如果你确实喜欢它，如果在 Apple Podcasts 上收听，请务必评分和评论。如果你在 Spotify 上，你可以给它评分。请给我留言、点赞、分享给你的朋友。订阅频道。这是你能为任何播客做出的最贴心的举动，而且完全免费。有什么理由不这样做呢？让我们深入正题，我期待在节目结束后与你交流。
Hi, just want to welcome our guests for today, Zainab Khan. Hi, Zainab, welcome back. Hi, welcome. Thank you. Thanks for being here. Obviously, we were in the same outfit, so we've done it on the same day, but we figured that it was worth having a separate conversation about breastfeeding and how to kind of understand that within a South Asian context. And that's because you have done research into this area of your undergrad psychology degree haven't you? Yes so my undergrad dissertation was essentially an acceptability study on a breastfeeding workbook
嗨，我只想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾扎伊纳布·汗。嗨，扎伊纳布，欢迎回来。嗨，欢迎。谢谢。谢谢你的到来。显然，我们穿着同样的衣服，所以我们是在同一天录制的，但我们觉得值得就母乳喂养以及如何在南亚背景下去理解母乳喂养进行一次单独的对话。这是因为你在本科心理学学位期间做过这个领域的研讨，对吗？是的，所以我的本科毕业论文本质上是一项关于母乳喂养工作手册的可接受性研究，
that was used it was off the back of research done by my supervisor into the disparity between women of a high BMI and not reaching their breastfeeding goals despite obviously World Health Organization recommendations and such and yeah so it was like an intervention workbook that we were just trying to get an acceptability study done for however I decided to sort of branch off and specifically look at it from a South Asian perspective and get the acceptability from South Asian women in particular. Main reason for that was I know from my own family history and sort of cultural knowledge that for us breastfeeding is such a golden standard it's like the golden liquid it's so widely spoken about and within my own family breastfeeding is really
该手册是根据我的导师的研究背景制作的，研究起因是高 BMI 女性在实现母乳喂养目标方面存在差距，尽管世界卫生组织（WHO）显然有相关推荐等等。所以，是的，这就像是一本干预工作手册，我们只是试图为其做一个可接受性研究。然而，我决定从南亚的角度出发，具体研究它，并特别获得南亚女性的可接受性。主要原因我知道从我自己的家族史和某种文化知识来看，对我们来说，母乳喂养是一个绝对的黄金标准，就像黄金液体一样，人们对此谈论得非常多。在我的家族中，母乳喂养真的
really highly encouraged so yeah I just thought it would be interesting to see well how would how would it be best to sort of attract their attention and sort of support them psychologically so yeah I recruited through online methods it was mainly through Instagram call outs with a family friend that runs like a baby class in Leicester and yeah so I sent them the workbook and they were being interviewed about their thoughts on on how they think that would have helped them through their own experiences. And there's a lot that came from it that I think is what really opened my tunnel into now really wanting to Amy Brown, who I interviewed for the podcast before. She does lots and lots of brilliant research into breastfeeding and the power of human milk and just feeding practices generally. But she's well worth looking out for to see if she's kind of branched in South Asian stuff as well but so an acceptability study that's where we're kind of checking that people like what we're about to launch into the world is it that it's doing what we hope it will do for different population yeah exactly that so it was literally just to get their thoughts on whether they think it's even worth doing do women I mean for me specifically I want to know with do the
非常非常受到鼓励。所以，是的，我只是觉得看看如何才能最好地吸引她们的注意力并在心理上支持她们会很有趣。因此，是的，我通过网络方法招募了对象，主要是通过在莱斯特（Leicester）经营婴儿班的家庭朋友在 Instagram 上发出的呼吁。是的，所以我把工作手册发给了她们，并就她们对这本手册如何通过她们自己的经历帮助过她们的想法对她们进行了采访。其中产生了很多内容，我认为这真正打开了我的思路，让我现在非常渴望——我之前在播客中采访过的艾米·布朗（Amy Brown）。她做了大量关于母乳喂养、母乳力量以及一般喂养实践的出色研究。但非常值得关注她，看看她是否也涉足了南亚相关的内容。所以可接受性研究，就是我们要检查人们是否喜欢我们即将推出到世上的东西，它是否在发挥我们希望它为不同群体发挥的作用？是的，完全如此。所以这字面意思就是为了解她们的想法，看她们是否认为这甚至值得去做。女性——我的意思是，对我和我具体想了解的来说，
South Asian women feel like this workbook is necessary would their own sort of peers appreciate a workbook to sort of support them reaching their breastfeeding goals I think a lot of the original research into why women don't a woman of a high BMI don't reach their breastfeeding goals does come down to sort of mind over matter not being being stigmatized or not feeling competent enough so I think that was the main push behind needing such a workbook but actually my interviews almost went very south away from the workbook and so much was brought up with regards to culturally the sort of difficulties that women have that regardless of their BMI that South Asian women have when it comes to breastfeeding and actually reaching their breastfeeding goals and even something as simple as clothing so obviously for
南亚女性是否觉得这本工作手册是必要的？她们自己的同龄人是否会赞赏一本支持她们实现母乳喂养目标的工作手册？我认为关于女性为什么不这样做的大多数最初研究——高 BMI 女性为什么没有达到她们的母乳喂养目标，确实归结为心态决定一切，没有被污名化或觉得不够自信。所以我认为这是需要这样一本工作手册的主要推动力。但实际上，我的采访几乎完全偏离了工作手册，并提出了很多关于女性在文化上面临的困难，无论她们的 BMI 如何，南亚女性在母乳喂养以及实际实现母乳喂养目标时所面临的困难，甚至像服装这样简单的事情。显然，对于
South Asians traditional wear can be quite heavy it can be quite complex and very much not the most breastfeeding friendly outfits I think almost the narrative of you need to attend these events and you need to wear this sort of attire really puts a lot of women off breastfeeding or they give up early because they have so many of these weddings and events to go to that they turn to bottle feeding even if that's not internally what they want to do or even at family functions if it's not appropriate to breastfeed in front of male counterparts and things like that very much discouraging than our culture of breastfeeding publicly there really needs to be more to sort of highlight those sort of psychological thought process behind doing engaging in breastfeeding especially when it comes to I guess the public breastfeeding whilst the workbook that we showed had a whole section
南亚人来说，传统服饰可能相当沉重、相当复杂，而且非常不适合母乳喂养。我认为，你需要参加这些活动并且你需要穿这种服装的这种叙事，真的让很多女性对母乳喂养望而却步，或者她们很早就放弃了，因为她们有太多这样的婚礼和活动要去，以至于她们转向了奶瓶喂养，即使这在内心并不是她们想要的。或者即使在家庭聚会上，如果在男性同伴等人面前母乳喂养不合适，这在很大程度上阻碍了我们文化中公开母乳喂养的习惯。真的需要做更多的事情来突出参与母乳喂养背后的那种心理思维过程，特别是在我看来，关于在公开场合母乳喂养。虽然我们展示的工作手册有一个完整的章节
on it the almost the narrative behind the actual workbook when it came to public breastfeeding was not so much assimilated to why women of South Asian descent don't engage in public breastfeeding I think for them it came down to a lot of cultural stigma and also stigma around doing it in front of males and and and it has to be done hidden and I think yeah it was interesting to kind of hear from their perspective of things they wish they had received when it came to their own experiences especially when it came to things associated with their weight being told they're not good enough by family or being told that because they're overweight you know their breast not good enough I mean that's quite similar to what the general narrative is for white Caucasian women as well from the research.
关于这个内容，但当谈到公开母乳喂养时，实际工作手册背后的叙事并没有太多与南亚血统女性不参与公开母乳喂养的原因相融合。我认为对她们来说，这归结为大量的文化污名，以及在男性面前这样做周围的污名，而且必须隐蔽地进行。所以，是的，听到她们对她们希望在自己的经历中得到的事情的看法很有趣，特别是在与体重相关的事情上，被家人告知她们不够好，或者被告知因为她们超重，你知道，她们的胸部不够好。我的意思是，这与研究中白人高加索女性的一般叙事非常相似。
But I think it was more deep rooted for South Asians in regards to their culture in particular, which I think was different. Yeah, so interesting. And I guess there's not necessarily a biological reason why somebody with a higher BMI can't produce breast milk. And I think certainly Professor Amy Brown's research seems to suggest that it's only 2% of women who can't produce enough milk to sustain their own yield. That's what the evidence tells us. But thinking about my experiences of having been a breastfeeding mother to both of my children, certainly in the early days when you're establishing feeding and when they're establishing feeding and when
但我认为对于南亚人来说，这在其独特的文化方面更加根深蒂固，我认为这是不同的。是的，太有趣了。我想，BMI 较高的人无法产生母乳不一定有生物学原因。而且我认为艾米·布朗教授的研究无疑表明，只有 2% 的女性无法产生足够的乳汁来维持她们自己的产量。这就是证据告诉我们的。但是想想我作为我两个孩子的母乳喂养母亲的经历，肯定在早期，当你正在建立喂养，当他们正在建立喂养，当
they are cluster feeding, which is really, really exhausting for mum actually, because you're getting almost, it feels like constant feeding. That is involving a lot of either top-off time or clever one-up, one-down outfit choices. And cultural dress may not always make that possible, especially when out and about. And it is really challenging, establishing breastfeeding, especially if you're being undermined by people around you. It's really, really difficult. You need somebody who, you don't always need somebody who gets why
他们进行集群喂养（cluster feeding）时，这对于妈妈来说实际上真的非常非常累，因为你会得到几乎感觉是持续喂养。这涉及大量的补奶时间或巧妙的一上一下的服装选择。文化服装可能并不总能让这一点成为可能，尤其是在外出时。建立母乳喂养真的具有挑战性，特别是如果你遭到周围人的破坏。这真的真的很难。你需要这样一个人——你并不总是需要一个明白
it's important to you, but it sure does help if someone is willing to bring you a pint of water as soon as you sit down to feed. Because if someone is trying to undermine you and constantly saying, oh, you know, perhaps they'd sleep better with formula or perhaps, you know, I would actually really like to feed them, you know, I'm going to feed them a bottle. That can affect a mother's mental health. It can affect how she's able to produce milk in future. Like it's a really big deal. Yeah, exactly. And I think speaking about South Asia in particular, I know that there was a huge brand that went into India years and years and years ago and introduced formula milk which was incentivized by free formula milk and things like that and it really really perpetuated this cycle that's really gone down tradition to tradition because it was linked so heavily
为什么这对你很重要的人，但如果有人愿意在你坐下来喂奶的那一刻给你端来一品脱水，那绝对会有所帮助。因为如果有人试图破坏你，不断地说，“哦，你知道，也许她们喝配方奶会睡得更好”，或者“哦，你知道，我其实真的想喂她们，你知道，我要给她们喂奶瓶。”这会影响母亲的心理健康。这会影响她将来产生乳汁的能力。这真的是一件大事。是的，完全如此。而且我认为特别谈到南亚，我知道很多年前有一个大品牌进入印度并引入了配方奶，这是通过免费配方奶等激励措施推动的，它真正地延续了这个代代相传的循环，因为它的广告与
their advertising was linked so heavily to well if you use formula you can do the housework you can get on with the chores you can look after your other children you can pass the baby from family member to family member it was really tying into certain cultural niches that it has I know it sustains such a long-standing tradition now within cultures that I actually wasn't aware of until I did this research just given that within my own family circle they've all been everyone's breastfed, it's very much spoken about, but after doing my dissertation, it really highlights to me, actually, almost the narrative
它们的广告与以下内容息息相关：如果你使用配方奶，你可以做家务，你可以继续做杂务，你可以照顾你的其他孩子，你可以把婴儿从一个家庭成员传给另一个家庭成员。它真的迎合了某些文化定位，我知道它在各种文化中维持了如此长久的传统，直到我做这项研究之前我甚至都不知道。鉴于在我自己的家庭圈子里，大家都是母乳喂养，每个人都谈论这个，但在做完我的毕业论文后，它真的向我强调，实际上，南亚人内部的叙事已经
slightly switched within South Asians, a lot of, actually, why don't we try formula, because it does mean that you can, because we're such family,
略有转变，很多人实际上在想：“为什么我们不尝试配方奶呢？”因为这确实意味着你可以——因为我们是如此以家庭
family orientated people, we have such large families, typically, it has been perpetuated a lot, that actually, if you do use formula, you know, you can just hand the baby
为中心的人，我们通常有这么大的家庭，这就得到了很大的延续：实际上，如果你使用配方奶，你知道，你就可以把孩子
off to grandma, or to aunties and uncles and while you get on with the housework and I think when it comes to then trying to implement psychological interventions or workbooks or anything that can sort of change the narrative around your breastfeeding behaviors and your approach to breastfeeding if the healthcare providers have that knowledge in mind or they just kind of do the almost preparatory work of what is going on for that coach in particular first before we create any sort of intervention I think they'll have a lot more efficacy and in how they kind of work I think again it also ties in with not necessarily all healthcare providers because you do get obviously some very good ones but I think the research that I've looked into anyway there is a huge disparity between the general perinatal support whether that's
交给奶奶，或者交给阿姨、叔叔，而你则去忙家务。我认为当涉及到试图实施心理干预或工作手册或任何可以改变围绕你的母乳喂养行为和母乳喂养方法的叙事的干预措施时，如果医疗保健提供者牢记这些知识，或者他们在我们创建任何类型的干预措施之前，先做一些关于特定文化中到底发生了什么的准备工作，我认为他们在工作方式上会有更高的效力和效果。我认为这也与不一定所有的医疗保健提供者有关，因为你显然会遇到一些非常优秀的医疗保健提供者，但我认为无论如何我研究过的研究表明，与白人高加索同行相比，南亚女性获得的总体围产期支持——无论是
psychological or practical medical help that South Asian women get in comparison to their white Caucasian counterparts so I think if systemically you've got healthcare providers that don't actually want to do the the kind of groundwork of understanding that culture's issues and problems, you're never going to kind of bridge the gap and increase those breastfeeding rates or increase any of the positive behaviours that should happen postnatally or even perinatally as well. And I, you know, whoever I'm supporting as a new mum, I'll always think, actually, we don't necessarily need them to come around and feed the baby. But if they're coming around, perhaps they could clean the bathroom whilst they're using it. Perhaps they could do the cleaning. Would that fly as an intervention
心理上的还是实际的医疗帮助——存在巨大的差异。所以我想，如果在体制上你有那些实际上不想做理解该文化的议题和问题的基础工作的医疗保健提供者，你将永远无法弥合差距并提高那些母乳喂养率，或者增加任何在产后甚至围产期应该发生的积极行为。而且我，你知道，无论我作为新妈妈支持谁，我总是会想，实际上，我们不一定需要他们过来喂养婴儿。但如果他们过来，也许他们可以在使用浴室时顺便打扫一下浴室。也许他们可以做清洁。作为对
for South Asian cultures? Or would that be frowned upon if I asked my auntie to clean my bathroom when she came around? Yeah, traditionally very frowned upon. I think it's very, it's almost women's bills are held to such a high standard which kind of works in a positive and negative light in some ways I think it's quite a common misconception that obviously women in my culture for example are like quite oppressed or they're not seen as as valuable individuals but I mean coming from like a religious point of view for me like religiously women and my within my family women are held to such a high standard in terms of they are the most valuable members of the community because of how much they have to enjoy whether it's childbirth and being a parent
南亚文化的干预，这行得通吗？或者如果我要求我的阿姨在我过来时打扫我的浴室，这会被皱眉吗？是的，传统上非常不受欢迎。我认为这非常，女性的义务几乎被认为具有如此高的标准，这在某些方面以积极和消极的方式发挥作用。我认为这是一个相当普遍的误解，即显然我文化中的女性，例如，相当被压迫，或者她们不被视为有价值的个人。但我的意思是，从宗教的角度来看，对我和我家族内的女性来说，在宗教上，女性享有如此高的标准，就她们必须承受的痛苦而言，她们是社区中最有价值的成员，无论是分娩还是为人父母
and so on so forth but I think sometimes that can be taken the wrong way where it's because so much is expected of them that's when sort of the psychological impact of just certain things like traumatic births which statistically South Asians have a very high experience of traumatic birth I think there was a it was Owen Mitchell that did a the first ever South Asian perinatal conference recently and I was reading the report of that and it was all about traumatic births and how statistics aren't being published about the high numbers of traumatic births experienced by South Asians but if people and not just healthcare providers but even family members and friends within the community aren't aware of the psychological impact of even just a normal birth let alone traumatic birth
等等。但我认为有时这会被误解，因为对她们提出了如此多的期望，这就是某些事情的心理影响开始发挥作用的时候，比如创伤性分娩——据统计南亚女性有非常高的创伤性分娩经历。我想欧文·米切尔（Owen Mitchell）最近举行了历史上第一次南亚围产期会议，我在阅读该会议的报告时，内容全部关于创伤性分娩，以及关于南亚人经历的创伤性分娩的高数字是如何没有被公布统计数据的。但如果人们——不仅是医疗保健提供者，甚至包括社区内的家庭成员和朋友——没有意识到即使是正常分娩的心理影响，更不用说创伤性分娩了，
they're so overlooked then that they're just expected to do a lot of the housework and things so I think it's a lot of it is there just has to be balance I think I think it's quite common within western culture to almost discredit cultural practices where they encourage sort of these very traditional gender roles or they see it as oppressive and the woman has to be submissive and it's not a good thing I think it ties back to what I've said in the previous episode with you where you have to see it from a culturally appropriate point of view where for us it's not a bad thing to be a domesticated person or a domesticated woman it's not a bad thing to be the one doing the cleaning but there also has to be a level of support from other people so yeah I mean if if it was in encouraged that you know when someone's a new mum let's help
那么她们就被严重忽视了，以至于她们被期望做大量的家务等等。所以我认为很多事情都必须有平衡。我认为在西方文化中，几乎不信任那些鼓励非常传统的性别角色的文化实践，或者认为它们是压迫性的，女性必须顺从而这不是一件好事，这很常见。我认为这可以追溯到我在上一集里对你所说的话，你必须从文化上合适的角度来看待它，对我们来说，成为一个顾家的或顾家的女性并不是一件坏事，成为那个做清洁的人并不是一件坏事，但同时也必须有来自其他人的支持水平。所以，是的，如果有人鼓励，你知道，当有人成为新妈妈时，让我们在做家务方面多帮一点忙，那将是极好的。但我认为在文化中引入这一点并不像说“为什么你下次不请你阿姨过来时帮忙打扫卫生呢”那么容易。我认为这就是巨大的区别。
out a little bit more with the housework that would be great but I think introducing that within the culture isn't as easy as just saying well why don't you ask your auntie next time to come like when she comes over to do the cleaning I think that's the big difference okay I really liked what you said in the previous episode about the parallels between the World Health Organization take on breastfeeding and the Quran could you tell us a bit more about that yeah so essentially word for word what you see in the WHO is written word for word what you see in the who is written word for word in regards to how many months they recommend breastfeeding the benefits of breast
好的，我很喜欢你在上一集中所说的话，关于世界卫生组织对母乳喂养的看法与《古兰经》之间的相似之处。你能多给我们讲讲这个吗？是的，所以基本上，你在世卫组织（WHO）看到的内容是逐字逐句写下来的。你在 WHO 看到的内容是逐字逐句写下来的。关于他们建议母乳喂养几个月、母乳喂养的好处
meat it's literally written word for word um in the ground as it is on the who website as well for me that was highlighted by i knew that anyway going into this research but i did notice across the interviews i did a lot of them did bring up they just happened to all be Muslim that I spoke to just by chance and they all in the way they were talking about their experiences of perinatal mental health and things like that they all brought in sort of a religious influence and sort of the maybe the comfort they found in prayer or turning to religious leaders and things like that and where they were getting their source of information and for me that highlights almost a need for healthcare providers and services to almost bring religion into it where it's appropriate because I
，这在《古兰经》中与 WHO 网站上的一模一样。对我来说，这是被强调的——在做这项研究之前我本来就知道这一点，但我确实注意到在我所做的采访中，很多人都提到了这一点。碰巧我采访的人碰巧都是穆斯林，而且在他们谈论围产期心理健康等经历的方式中，他们都融入了某种宗教影响，以及他们在祈祷或转向宗教领袖等方面找到的慰藉，以及他们获取信息来源的地方。对我来说，这突显了医疗保健提供者和服务机构几乎需要在适当的时候将宗教融入其中的必要性。因为我认为，
think again just in the world we live in they're always seen as quite taboo topics or you don't bring religion into things or you don't but I think for a lot of these services especially ones that aren't educated in England or in western cultures or that haven't ever engaged with any education providers at all if they've migrated from abroad or anything like that for them they might turn to religious books for their almost education and I think if there was some knowledge of that from you know psychological providers service providers I think it's not necessarily a bad thing I think you'd was some knowledge of that from you know psychological providers service providers I think it's not necessarily a bad thing I think you'd get a lot more reach and a lot more response I just thought it was very interesting to be honest yeah even just to know to ask the question
同样，在我们生活的世界里，它们总是被视为相当禁忌的话题，或者你不会把宗教带入事情中，或者你不会。但我认为对于许多这些服务，特别是那些没有在英国或西方文化中受过教育的服务，或者如果他们从国外移民等，从来没有接触过任何教育提供者的服务，对他们来说，他们可能会转向宗教书籍作为他们几乎教育的来源。并且我认为，如果心理提供者、服务提供者对此有一些了解，我认为这不一定是一件坏事。我认为你会获得
is there anything in your faith or your culture or your you know your cultural and religious books that talks about this that might be you know explaining some of what we're seeing right now but I seem to remember working with women in the past who really they recognized that they weren't ready to stop breastfeeding their child and that the baby the child wasn't ready to stop but I seem to remember there was some understanding that it was to stop by two years of age. Does that ring a bell for you, Zainab? Yeah, I think the actual, I should really know this off by heart given that I did research into it, but the WHO recommendation, I know that it's exclusive breastfeeding up to six months
更多的接触和更多的回应。老实说，我只是觉得这非常有趣。是的，甚至只是知道如何问这个问题：你的信仰、文化中，或者你的文化和宗教书籍中是否有任何关于这方面的讨论，可能会解释我们现在所看到的一些情况？但我似乎记得过去与女性合作过，她们真的认识到自己还没有准备好停止母乳喂养她们的孩子，而婴儿、孩子也没有准备好停止。但我似乎记得有一些理解，即应该在两岁时停止。这听起来耳熟吗，扎伊纳布？是的，我想实际的——鉴于我对此进行了研究，我真的应该把这个铭记于心，但世卫组织的建议，我知道它是前六个月纯母乳喂养，
and then it's supposed to be introduced alongside obviously solids up to two years. So yeah, you're right in saying that yeah but it's i guess speaking as a mother who did feed both of our children past two years one was 25 months and one i had to put a line under it at two years and 10 months it's it's it's kind of at least two years is how i remember the guidance but that is uh i think in, in certain South Asian cultures, it's seen as you mustn't go beyond that. It becomes inappropriate or not OK. But of course, what we know, the woman who has breastfed, is that it's a very individual relationship between you and that child. And, you know, trying to stop for an external reason rather than a reason that is about you or about that baby choosing to make that stop.
然后据推测应该在两岁之前与辅食一起引入。所以，是的，你说得对，是的。但我想作为一个母乳喂养过两个孩子超过两岁的母亲来说——一个是 25 个月，另一个我不得不在两岁 10 个月时画上句号——我记忆中的指导方针至少是两岁。但那是，我认为在某些南亚文化中，这被视为你绝不能超越这个界限。这变得不合适或不OK。但当然，我们所知道的——母乳喂养过的女性——是，这是你和那个孩子之间非常独特的私人关系。而且，你知道，试图因为外部原因而停止，而不是因为关于你或关于那个孩子选择停止的原因。
So it's said there's only two times where you should stop breastfeeding and that's if it doesn't work for you or it doesn't work for baby but of course having separate guidance around do not continue beyond two years can can add lots of elements of guilt shame and regret and blame and and very difficult kind of mental processes that are there yeah you're absolutely right i mean i mean going back to religious scriptures it mirrors it's only a guidance it's not that you have to suffer two years. But I think culturally, a lot of it comes into, I think, I mean, the intervention that we were looking at, there was so much talk about, you know, talk about your body is like, get your breasts out, like, explore and things like that. I think one thing that I discussed a lot with the interviewees was it's not culturally appropriate to get your breasts out. Exposing body parts is not a thing that we do. with the interviewees was it's not culturally appropriate to get your breasts out exposing body parts is not a thing that we do even talking about it within the work with your husband
所以据说只有两个时候你应该停止母乳喂养，那就是如果这对你不合适或者对婴儿不合适。但当然，围绕“不要持续超过两岁”的单独指导方针会增加许多内疚、羞耻、遗憾和责备的元素，以及非常困难的心理过程。是的，你绝对说得对。我的意思是，回到宗教经文，它反映了它只是一种指导，并不是说你必须忍受两年。但我想在文化上，很多时候，我——我们正在看的那项干预，有很多关于“谈论你的身体，比如把你的乳房露出来，探索等等”的讨论。我认为我和受访者深入讨论的一件事是，把你的乳房露出来在文化上是不合适的。暴露身体部位不是我们做的事。与受访者的讨论是，把你的乳房露出来在文化上是不合适的。暴露身体部位不是我们做的事。甚至在工作手册中与你的丈夫谈论它
not also very much encouraged like the exploratory side of things that you know what positions like for you and so on and so forth just even something as small as that wasn't very much encouraged because of cultural shame and stigma almost I guess you could call it I think again I don't think it's necessarily should be seen as a bad thing I just think again it's just a cultural preference that we especially if you come from a Muslim background or typically any religious background within South Asia it's that you you maintain your modesty and things like that especially when it comes to your male counterparts or family members or friends and I think yeah so when it comes to obviously going past certain ages you're right
也不是很受鼓励，比如探索性的一面，你知道什么姿势适合你等等。仅仅是像这样小的事情，由于文化耻辱和羞耻感，几乎可以说，并没有得到太多的鼓励。我认为，同样，我不认为这一定应该被视为一件坏事，我只是认为这再次只是我们的文化偏好，特别是如果你来自穆斯林背景或南亚的任何典型的宗教背景，那就是你保持你的谦逊等等，特别是在面对你的男性同伴、家庭成员或朋友时。我认为，是的，所以当涉及到超越特定年龄时，你是对的，
it does come down to I guess the stigma around oh that's a bit inappropriate to look at for whatever reason that's I don't know where that idea has even come from but it just I think from the like research and healthcare provider point of, it shouldn't be about questioning where has that come from. More so, it's there. It's not going to disappear. Because a lot of these cultural issues or cultural beliefs, they stem from generations ago. It's not something you can change overnight.
这确实归结为围绕“无论出于什么原因，看着都有点不合适”的污名。我不知道这个想法是从哪里来的，但它只是——我认为从研究和医疗保健提供者的角度来看，不应该去质疑这究竟是从哪里来的。更多的是，它就在那里。它不会消失。因为许多这些文化问题或文化信仰，它们源于几代人之前。这不是一朝一夕就能改变的事情。
You can't tackle almost where it's come from. I think that's a lot of the focus when it comes to research. Well, where's this shame coming from? Let's tackle the where. I think it needs to just be that it's there anyway assume it's there and deal with it in that way instead I think almost giving them just an alternative point of view a lot of South Asian women stopping exactly two years because of that shame that comes after all this yeah and I think I know even myself as I was talking just then about how long I'd fed my children for, I had this kind of internal critic like, oh, should you be saying
你几乎无法解决它究竟从何而来的问题。我认为这往往是研究的重点。好吧，这种羞耻感从何而来？让我们解决根源。我认为它应该只是——反正它就在那里，假设它就在那里，并以这种方式处理。相反，我认为几乎是给她们提供一个替代的观点，许多南亚女性由于这种随后产生的羞耻感而在恰好两岁时停止。是的，而且我认为，甚至当我刚才谈到我喂养孩子多久时，我自己也有这种内在的批评：“哦，你应该说这个吗？”
this? Should you be publicly telling people that you'd fed for this length of time? And will people think that you're judging them or slighting them if they didn't feed for that. It's really hard, but I'm proud to have fed my children. It was not easy. It was incredibly difficult. Both of them had tongue ties as well, but having a child is not easy. And for me, that was just something that I was adamant that I was going to make work. And thankfully, I wasn't one of the two percent of women that couldn't produce enough milk you know there are medical reasons why some people can't do that and there's sometimes personal preference reasons and when it comes to kind of trauma and abuse obviously there's this absolutely complicates whether someone feels they want to or
“你应该公开告诉别人你喂养了这么长时间吗？如果他们没有喂养这么长时间，人们会认为你在评判他们或轻视他们吗？”这真的很难，但我为母乳喂养我的孩子感到自豪。这并不容易。这非常困难。他们两个都有舌系带过短（tongue ties）的问题，但生孩子并不容易。对我来说，这只是我坚决要让它起作用的事情。谢天谢地，我不是那百分之二无法产生足够乳汁的女性之一。你知道，有些人做不到是有医学原因的，有时也有个人偏好的原因。当涉及到创伤和虐待时，显然这绝对会让一个人是否觉得想要或
can breastfeed but I guess it's what we said before, like in the first episode, like if you can see it, you can be it. You know, if you've heard Dr. Marianne Trent talking about having breastfed her children beyond two years, maybe that thing makes you think, well, I can work. I can go back to work. I went back to work with both babies a year of age. And I expressed, you know, I think this is just, we need to be getting better at asking people for their story, for what matters to them, for what external and internal factors might be perpetuating some of these difficulties, all these struggles, these challenges. You know, we should be empowering people, ourselves, people in our team, people above us, people below us to have these conversations.
能够母乳喂养变得复杂。但我想这就是我们之前所说的，就像在第一集里一样，如果你能看到它，你就能成为它。你知道，如果你听过玛丽安·特伦特博士谈论她在孩子两岁之后还进行母乳喂养，也许那件事会让你觉得，“好吧，我可以工作。我可以回去工作。”我在两个孩子一岁时都回去工作了。我挤奶。你知道，我认为这只是，我们需要更好地询问人们的故事、对他们来说重要的是什么、哪些外部和内部因素可能在延续其中一些困难、所有的挣扎、这些挑战。你知道，我们应该赋予人们权力，我们自己、我们团队中的人、我们上面的人、我们下面的人，让他们进行这些对话。
And I guess it's really difficult, especially as a white British woman. I don't want to get things wrong. I don't want to be making't know. We cannot be an expert in everything. Podcasts like this help to illuminate areas that we might not even have considered before. But really, the person themselves is always going to be the expert on themselves, aren't they? Yes. I think that literally sums up perfectly. I think it is. The big thing that I'm so interested in is, I think where it's almost going wrong is at the baseline. I think, especially for South Asian women, given that culturally they can be quite stereotypically seen as, you know, submissive characters or they don't get their voices heard I think that's where
而且我认为这真的很困难，特别作为一名白人英国女性。我不想弄错。我不想——我不知道。我们不可能成为所有事情的专家。像这样的播客有助于照亮我们以前甚至可能没有考虑过的领域。但实际上，这个人本身永远会是他们自己的专家，对吗？是的。我认为这简直完美地总结了这一切。我认为是的。我非常感兴趣的大事是，我认为出错的地方几乎是在基准线上。我认为，特别对于南亚女性，鉴于在文化上她们可能会被刻板印象视为，你知道，顺从的角色或者她们的声音听不到，我认为这就是
as a researcher or as a healthcare provider a clinical psychologist you really have to be the one that does empower them to speak and I think it goes down to being exploratory and just curious I think at the start of meeting a client if you're asking them almost give me everything about your life story so I can understand would do us a lot more good than it does harm than if we were to ask something and maybe trot on the wrong foot slightly and get something wrong that we don't understand I think that's better to do almost than if you just don't ask and you just assume that they fit the sort of same narrative that we've seen for countless years I think especially when it comes to sort of perinatal mental health I think going forward for South Asians like my biggest thing is I want to be the representation for as a clinician or as a researcher to almost like be the like the bridging gap between I think the
作为一名研究人员或医疗保健提供者、临床心理学家，你真的必须是那个赋予她们说话权力的人。并且我认为这归结为具有探索性和好奇心。我认为在刚见到客户时，如果你要求她们几乎把她们的人生故事的方方面面都告诉我，以便我能理解，这带给我们的好处要远远大于坏害处，总好过我们去问某个问题却稍微踩错了脚，弄错了我们不理解的事情。我认为这总比不问、并且只假设她们符合我们多年来看到的相同叙事要好。我认为，特别是在围产期心理健康方面，我认为对于南亚人未来的发展，我最大的愿望是，我想作为一名临床医生或研究人员成为这种代表，几乎成为——我认为
big thing that we spoke about even in the previous episode is just representation if you can have some representation somewhere in a service that understands or that can just show that I think like what you said before with if you can see it you can believe it if you can see yourself almost a representation of yourself within your healthcare provisions you're more likely to want to engage and you're more likely to believe what's being said than if it's someone that doesn't emulate the same beliefs or even look the same as you thank you so much please could you let us know where people can kind of connect with you and learn more about your research i would probably
我们在上一集中谈论的大事只是代表性。如果你在某个服务机构中能有一些代表性，能够理解或能够展现这一点——我想就像你之前所说的，如果你能看到它，你就能相信它；如果你能在你的医疗保健服务中看到你自己的代表性，你就会更愿意参与，并且你更有可能相信所说的话，而不是一个不体现相同信仰甚至长相与你不同的人。非常感谢，请告诉大家人们可以在哪里与你联系并了解更多关于你的研究？我可能会
say linkedin is the best place to go for that um it's just my name, Zainab Khan, and you'll find me. Thank you so much for helping illuminate our listeners and our watchers about this really important issue. Thanks for your time. Thank you so much, Avowee. It's been really, really, really good to speak on the podcast today. Oh, thank you. Thank you so much once again to Zainab for her time in speaking with me. What has this brought up for you?
说领英（LinkedIn）是最好的去处。那就是我的名字，扎伊纳布·汗（Zainab Khan），你就能找到我。非常感谢你帮助我们的听众和观众了解这个非常重要的问题。谢谢你的时间。非常感谢，Avowee。今天能在播客中发言真的非常非常棒。哦，谢谢。再次非常感谢扎伊纳布抽出时间与我交谈。这唤起了你什么样的感受？
Please do come and let me know on my social media, where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Come and let me know what you think and watch Marianne's motivation and mindset videos, which you can do totally for free by joining my free Facebook group, The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. If it's your time and you're ready for the next step, please do consider the Aspiring Psychologist membership,
请务必来我的社交媒体告诉我，我到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）。快来告诉我你的想法，并观看玛丽安的动力与思维视频，你可以通过加入我的免费 Facebook 群组——由玛丽安·特伦特博士创立的有抱负的心理学家社区（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）——完全免费地观看这些视频。如果时机成熟，你准备好迈出下一步了，请务必考虑加入有抱负的心理学家会员计划（Aspiring Psychologist membership），
which you can join for just £30 a month with no minimum term. But if you did want to join for a longer period of time, you can get some free one-to-one time with me by signing up for six months or for nine months in one go. There's more details on my website. Please do also check out the Inspiring Psychologist Collective book and the Clinical Psychologist Collective book too. If you've got any future episodes, ideas, please do get in touch and let me know. Thank you so much for being part of my world.
你只需每月支付 30 英镑即可加入，没有最低期限要求。但如果你确实想加入更长时间，可以通过一次性注册六个月或九个月来获得与我的一对一免费时间。更多详情请访问我的网站。也请查看《有抱负的心理学家合集》（Inspiring Psychologist Collective）一书以及《临床心理学家合集》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）一书。如果你有任何未来的节目想法，请务必与我联系并告诉我。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。
If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Thank you so much for being part of my world. With Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay
如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么就让这本书作为你的指南。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。与玛丽安·特伦特博士合作。我叫雅娜（Jana），我是一名见习心理健康从业人员。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现其中关于所有不同故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。这让我惊叹于通往那里的途径竟然有这么多，而且没有成为其中一员的完美方式，这让我充满信心：不，我没有做错，并且减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的，
but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。